So is there any hope of doing better?
In fact, there's a big clue in the way
we've described the algorithms so far.
Remember that the BFS
visits the graph in waves.
Now this wavy nature of a BFS has
two really important implications.
First, an upper bound on the span
shouldn't be the number of vertices.
Instead, it ought to be
the number of waves.
let's give each wave,
which consists of all the vertices at
the same distance from the source,
a special name.
Call them levels.
So here's a question for you, what is
an upper limit on the number of levels?
One answer comes from
a particular property of a graph,
called it's diameter.
The diameter is basically the maximum
shortest distance between any pair of
vertices.
Now here's an important
point about diameter.
It's a property of the whole graph,
so that makes it only an upper bound
on the number of levels
from any starting vertex.
For example, I claim that this graph
has a diameter of 5, and that's
despite the fact that the shortest
distance from S to any vertex is 4.
Can you see why the diameter is 5?
I smell a quiz.
Now the process of visiting in a graph,
level by level is sometimes called
a level synchronous traversal, and
that leads us to the second big idea.
If you perform a level synchronous BFS,
then it shouldn't matter in what order
you visit the vertices
of any given level.
So if I take level two for example,
the fact that I visit this node,
before this node or
this node, before this node.
Really shouldn't matter.
After all, they get the same distance.
Let's be a little bit more precise.
Imagine running a BFS, and
stopping it at some level, call it L.
Now let's look at any two
unvisited neighbors of the set.
Now these both have to be a distance
of just one away from the set, so
it doesn't matter which
one we see first.
In face, we can even look
at them at the same time,
because they'll both
have the same value.